I'm Kennedy for recent TV sitting down
today with journalists Michael Moynihan
who has managed to upset a brand new
group of people I love your recent
article in foreign policy thank you so
others didn't puffers in the travel
industry in the travel industry did not
so you found that travel guides are
loaded with communist propaganda did you
come to that conclusion travel guide
writers I found or obsessed with
authenticity what does authenticity mean
to a travel writer when you talk about
Cuba for instance there's always this
instinct to say well you have to go
before it gets spoiled it's like an
artisanal kind of culture where you know
we eat rice and beans because there's
nothing else comrade it's not as if this
is some sort of choice to not have
coca-cola advertising to not have fancy
new cars that you'll find this with
people all the time say isn't it
adorable when you go to Havana that they
have all these Packard's from the 1950s
well no it's not I mean this is a pretty
grim reflection of the economics of Cuba
I mean they would like to have a Ford
Fiesta but were the only people on earth
that would like to have a Ford Fiesta
because there's no other alternative
there's nothing authentic there's
nothing cute it's not sort of time
travel for people for the Cubans that
live there it's a pretty [ __ ]
miserable existence Afghanistan is an
interesting one there's a bit about the
burka and there's a quote in it says
it's a Western construct that this is
oppressive to women this is actually a
great tool for social mobility a
patriarchal society in a classic sense
not in the sort of college feminists an
actual patriarchal society where women's
social mobility is constrained to
non-existent they are it's dictated that
they're covered from head to toe in
something resembling a tarp where
nothing is exposed that that is a tool
of social mobility is something that is
so absurd that it can only be described
as sort of orientalism as the same it's
the idea that no one culture is better
than the other which is not true when I
say is flat it's not true so you had an
interesting part about North Korea I
mean it seems like that would be a
difficult sell well traveling to North
Korea is not only difficult but when you
get there you don't have any choices
you're guided along by
weird apparatchiks and strange Lego hair
and sort of neighbor suits they tell you
where to go there is so much moral
equivalence in the book that I was
talking about about Korea the brant
guide to North Korea to say that Kim
Jong Il is a pragmatist you know in what
universe is this [ __ ] sociopath
pragmatic do you think it's immoral for
people to travel to places like North
Korea Afghanistan Iran Cuba to go to a
place like this the ethical issue I
leave to the traveler and I think I
ended the piece and saying that banning
travel to certain places like Cuba has
had no effect on totalitarian regimes if
you're traveling to Cuba for instance
there are people that have little
restaurants in their houses to give
somebody twenty dollars in Cuba where
the average wage and keep his nineteen
dollars a month no to give them twenty
dollars directly is a fantastic thing I
know people who have brought books down
to Cuba books that are banned in Spanish
that's also a good thing I think that it
has a positive effect in a place like
Iran where an Iranian czar a very
pro-american country that is a point
that is sharpened by Americans traveling
there and they realize that they're not
sort of fanned and horned and you know
sweaty demons of verenia propagandas
thank you Michael thank you 4recent Evie
I'm Kennedy